I want to share with you some more one
roll yard sees which have been sent in
by numberphile viewers and there's a few
reasons I want to share these firstly
because I said I would people have gone
to a lot of trouble making these videos
and I really think we should share them
secondly it's a pretty cool thing to see
you remember from previous videos
there's only your one in 1296 chance of
rolling one so when you get it it's
pretty good and lastly I think it's
fascinating to see how people react when
they finally roll one yes so let's go
through some more viewer videos some of
them are quite funny some of them some
of them are a bit strange
here Anthony rolls five fours there it
is a bit over par there but what an
effort and how's this for a reaction
from Bill Vincent now here's the Benton
family going for glory
I'm not sure the kids were too into it
to be honest but perhaps it was a chance
to stay up late
if so their luck was out because it only
took 54 rolls
Jacob here hit pretty much a power score
of 1,300 rolls but what a reaction James
foster here hit the jackpot with his 800
and second roll and I know it took him
eight hundred and two rolls because he
sent me every single one of them in real
time Jesse Davis thought many hands
would make light work clever thinking
but remarkably it took them a combined
5064 roles until this happened 17-year
old Josh looks like he broke out the
fancy Bowl for this attempt now Lorenzo
here did it with software I don't think
that's quite getting into the spirit of
things but clever anyway here's Matthews
I did it I did it yes yes you did
and another Matthew who really put in
the hard yards
39 and 1639 there it is
and now to tyler's 1471 rolls and two
handed Tyler who did it in just 245
rolls yes now Mike Tilly here started
with a plate
he clearly got sick of the noise and
there was a lot of it because here we go
3951 rolls until this yes I got it now
patient Polly was rewarded with my
favorite Yahtzee five sixes and another
ol sixer but this one took just 143
rolls hello Rochelle hi Brady I'm
sitting around at home waiting for the
police to call me back I filed a report
about some credit card fraud my online
report didn't get accepted for some
reason so I'm waiting for an officer to
call me back that always takes forever
so I figured well I'm waiting around I
may as well try to roll a Yahtzee
there were shells if it took so long she
even changed hairstyles 1116 rolls took
me two days here are my hash marks so
let's recap after only 106 rolls the
police called me back
Robson here gets extra points for the
numberphile branding and for over three
hours of effort
here's William Alves and I don't know
how to pronounce your name a crew may
but you were definitely one of our more
excited dice rollers
now Simon from Germany who's already
forgiven me for not being able to
pronounce his surname did the business
in less than two hours yeah
and here's Xavier who rolled these
strange poker dice two thousand five
hundred and fifty nine times yeah
Steven Christie rolled these five fives
in 1190 rolls but he thought that last
dice looked a bit dodgy so he had
another guy rolling a Yahtzee and the
second time it took him about four
hundred rolls Stowe Farrell took an
impressive 525 rolls to roll fire fives
yes and he tells me he hit four of a
kind
eleven times before the big moment oh I
did it
and finally fellow Australian Simon
Brown and this reaction well it sounds a
bit familiar that's it I've done a will
D RT but I've done it I have rolled a
Yahtzee
that must be an Australian thing feel
free to keep sending in your one
railyard C's I actually really enjoy
watching them and you know I'll make
another video